hello hello hey where are you wait for
me I'm coming welcome back to hell
health coke the most Awkward title you
could ever say my name is parrot I never
forgot say pupa and we're gonna continue
we'll probably gonna finish it I don't
know we'll see I know
jesus [ __ ] christ this game has a lot
of jump scares okay it's not what why do
not didn't like it it is
that's [ __ ] creepy oh hell no [ __ ]
you ugly what I'm sorry no your nice
dress
scold her hug her or shake the room
[ __ ] that [ __ ] I'll check the room
excuse me okay that went better than
expected
oh look so creepy hey hey I like my I
like my outfit I look like Alex I know
not God I said that guy named Nisha what
the [ __ ]
hello Harry listen I'm not dead not yet
I'm a laugh I have a future I love you
what you put your soul to rest a [ __ ]
I'm sorry you're ugly now huh huh what
do you mean my bad end wrong number so
that was the ending that was ending
right there you passed on no no no no
don't no no you can't do that [ __ ] to me
you're telling me I have to replay the
entire [ __ ] game what what in the
hell why is it mirrored why am i okay
this is freaking them pizza like this
hmm
laces misses mine [ __ ] me too much I
don't like getting [ __ ] especially not
in my mind
hello okay I can't listen I'm not that
night oh oh I get it
do you get it I caught it before you got
it probably not I'm sorry I love you why
don't you put your soul to rest
the girl I just want to watch Netflix
okay just leave me alone
sorry sorry I'll just watch YouTube in
25 hello Carrie hello hey where are you
I know you pieces I'm tired I'm tense
that let's be nice this is a really
unique game I actually love it I like it
it's so weird it's so different I have
no idea what the [ __ ] is happening is
that a Beatles reference oh [ __ ] here we
go again
blood sticks to the mirror I don't fit
not in the mood to read what about some
wine all isn't good
oh the mood fallen she she just [ __ ]
chug much hangover yeah
best ending ever god dammit alright we
need we need a photo I left the Teddy
that's Anna it feels almost alive are
you gonna touch my ass okay okay are you
gonna kill yourself
yep I knew that [ __ ] because I my ass is
too fine it's heads off what's the point
of that be poppin on appreciate oh hello
Kisuke that call I got is it it was from
you right enough of this okay
I'm not doing any it's not doing any
good for us you bros understand I feel
like this game hasn't really like a
meaning something that I'm not noticing
yet what's that sound like oh it's oh
baby baby it's a wild world on the TV
this is so many things okay I got it
ah Jesus Christ man like hey you know
what we should do we should make a
horror game with a gazillion jumps case
hello Kawasaki what do you want from me
all right we've been through this [ __ ]
before you want to move
oh Jesus Christ Jericho in two days
it'll be six years of dating a car I
suppose I should treat her to a special
meal I'll bet you love it
akari said she has an important business
trip tomorrow what a shame
I had president of everything today
makes six years okay I know work is
rough for you too I'm sorry for what I
said on the phone yesterday i Carrie
called and said she'll be back tomorrow
it's it's it's felt like so long I
should meet her at the airport
then she's end here I'm sorry
Kisuke I'm sorry so it's kind of the
same perspective and same diff
sweetheart diary Jesus Christ this game
has a lot of ending they should hello
hello hey where are you wait for me I
hope they meet up in yen I got the back
what do you want from me Kazuki here we
go here we go again I'll come see you
tomorrow I don't want you to come see me
tomorrow I am fine with my life as it is
and noted how's that an ending I'm oh
[ __ ] I should come
I don't want to do it
stop Kazik a
I carries that you are cutting cough
cough I carry hold out your hand come
quick Kisuke where are you
oh he she can't see him how the [ __ ] am
I supposed to get a good end I don't
understand
oh [ __ ] that was close what I clicked on
the fireplace I don't know what happened
another lover I guess we did it
hello again did I first again I think I
said no that matter was nothing
fireplace connects of what my brain
can't cope with this hmm goddamnit
who is this are you bitching you know
what fireplace connects the world I'll
go to the fire hello
I carry really and one end one I'm
coming to see you
I know all right
I press we are back and it seems that
you could actually finish this game here
so I think we're gonna try to get the
ending Erica
I got it hi all right here we go again
we scold her
I carry I'm not dead not yet I'm alive I
have a future I love you why don't you
put your soul to rest that [ __ ] didn't
work
poor a communicator god damn it
okay let's try this again I can't die
let's give her a hug you know what let's
hug that ugly ghost because I wish I had
my razor hydros I can do it ah
oh [ __ ] where's her face what is it
doing down there
I don't I won't let you be alone I'll do
whatever I can
I won't leave you really yeah really
really really yeah even though you're
ugly as [ __ ]
really really I mean really really I'm
glad
ah there we go
isn't that a door ah happy end they're
together we're together alright
we're dead of breath you've passed on I
know
hi well [ __ ] see you alright Bryce I
hope you enjoyed this series a very
short game but it was really fun and I
actually really really liked it because
it was different
it took different in our horror way
different horror way I hope you bros
enjoyed watching leave a like if you did
and if you want more RPG maker horror I
know there's a couple that I haven't
played anyhow stay awesome bros
here comes the brofist are you seriously
not brofist I got a broke this that
simple come on do it
one two three
yes yes give me that [ __ ]
give me that Oh